The joe rogan experience.
I'll tell you what the problem is,
Graham Hancock is the children.
Where you're,
you're ignoring is you're endorsing drug use to children.
And I think that's incredibly irresponsible.
That's exactly what Ted said
when they banned my tool.
What did they,
what did that statements,
they said,
we can't allow this talk to be on the air because some young man might go off to
South America and drink IOWASCA.
That's so hilarious.
Ted cannot be seen to be endorsing the drinking of Iowa.
Is that the w there was a huge issue with you.
And by the way,
your issue was after Eddie Wong came in here and told his gross story that makes
you just go eat who?
Ted.
Apparently John Anthony West has a 10 story as well.
Um,
and I think that there's,
uh,
a lot of beautiful things that come out of tet.
A lot of incredible tools.
But it seems like any organization,
once people get into power and once people have the ability to tell other people
what's cool and what's not cool,
it's not.
It's getting weird and you start telling Eddie Wong he has to attend all these
different things and meet all these donors and like some kind of freaky cult.
Well that's what he felt like.
You felt like it was really strange.
Now your,
your thing got pulled and what was this scientific explanation for why they got
pulled?
It was there was you,
you had an exchange with one of the guys on Ted.
I read the comments and you presented all the things that he had said and said,
please show your example of when I said this,
I never said this.
Yeah.
What were the very,
what was the thing that he accused you of and what was the response were two of
us who got our talks deleted Rupert Sheldrake.
Rupert Sheldrake is the other,
his toe.
It was called the science delusion.
My Toe.
It was called the war on consciousness.
He can't be shitting on science like the science to illusion.
Rupert,
how dare you poked it was as though
if it was as though Ted felt that these talks must automatically be wrong and
that they had some kind of preconception about what we were saying.
So they didn't even bother to sit down and listen to the actual 18 minute talks,
not that much to listen to,
you know,
before deleting it from their youtube channel.
They just said this is pseudoscience.
Uh,
it's full of,
and they listed a series of false statements that would supposedly made,
but the problem was neither.
I know Rupert had made those statements
so they never even bothered to look at it and they just read complaints and then
responding plotted
on the basis of those.
So when we challenged them,
okay,
please go through,
in my case,
go through my talk and,
and find where I say that Iowasca allows you to communicate with an ancient
mother culture.
Where do I say that?
I never said that in my talk.
I never said any such thing in my talk.
They actually couldn't do it.
And,
and something you've said before,
no,
I've never seen,
I've never seen it right now.
I heard you.
What,
you know,
what I talked about was the mother goddess,
right?
The experience of an encounter with a mother,
God is by,
it never said it allows you to communicate with an ancient mother culture,
like a lost civilization.
They knew I'd written books about lost civilizations,
so they thought I must be bringing the,
my lust civilization beef into the,
into my ted talk,
which I did.
And it didn't have anything to do with lost.
It was a talk about,
talk about consciousness anyway.
And the real,
the original version was giving up the green bitch where you were talking to
recently.
I originally called the talk,
giving up the green.
That's when I watch us because I was giving my personal story of,
of,
of uh,
you know,
why I,
why I gave up cannabis.
Um,
I changed that title because a lot of people pointed out to me that that's
deeply disrespectful of cannabis and that for many people,
cannabis is a green goddess and cannabis was a green goddess for me.
And I accepted that.
So those people,
I'd say fucking relax.
Okay.
Cause I love cannabis too.
But it didn't bother me.
Some people got really upset.
I realized that to be upset,
I realized that there is in fact a cannabis orthodoxy as well,
which I wish my wish by talking about my,
my,
my quitting of cannabis,
I had upset this orthodoxy.
But when I looked at my talk,
my talk was much more about the war on consciousness than it was about fat.
And that's what it was really about.
So for example,
I made the point that,
um,
our society doesn't object in principle to altering consciousness.
I mean,
what happens when you put a kid on Ritalin?
You know,
that's a powerful pharmacological drug,
which is altering consciousness when you win,
you over prescribed Prozac or Ciroc sat for conditions of depression that those
drugs are altering consciousness.
We value alcohol,
we invest multibillion dollar alcohol industry.
People don't primarily raped,
drink alcohol because of the taste.
They drink it because it alters their consciousness in a way that they like.
And,
and so we don't object to altering consciousness in principle,
but we object to altering consciousness in certain kinds of ways,
which threaten the status quo.
And that's what psychedelics do.
They alter consciousness in ways that lead people to ask profound questions
about the nature of the society they live in.
And that appears to be the line that I crossed.
So Ted tied to try to dress it up as pseudoscience.
And when I called them on that in the end because they realized I think that
they were,
they'd got themselves into some kind of danger and it's still there on the,
on the webpage that w Rupert and I call it,
they're naughty corner,
they created a naughty corner of the Ted website where I talked to him quick
back on line and that with all their reasons why they'd taken them off.
So first thing they did was they crossed out all their reasons.
So you can find that everything they said has actually been crossed out.
And then they published our rebuttal.
So that completely,
we know,
we insisted that they,
they accepted that nothing they'd said was true,
but we insisted they leave it there on the public record,
but put a line through it.
Oh Wow.
So that,
so that they did that.
They did that.
Oh my God,
it did that.
And then they kind of a cool victory.
I know,
I know.
And they've published our rebuttals in full,
but it wasn't a complete victory because what they didn't do,
which is all we wanted was for our talks to burry reinstated on the TEDX youtube
channel.
No,
no,
no.
You can't put your tea,
your talk online yourself.
Well,
no,
I've,
I have put my talk online myself and,
and,
and so have about a hundred other youtube channels.
And,
and I think Ted took such a massive beating over this for big,
because it clearly was an act of censorship.
However,
they tried to dress it up that they've decided not to go and pull,
uh,
the talks from,
from Youtube,
which probably probably they could do.
So,
I mean,
my talk had 132,000 views on youtube on their channel when they pulled it.
But since then it's had hundreds of thousands of more views all over the
internet.
So,
you know,
they the,
rather than actually suppressed the talk,
I think it's called the Streisand effect.
You know,
rather than suppress the talks,
they ended up multiplying.
Same,
but same with root cause effect.
Apparently.
Apparently that,
I think it was Barbara Streisand tried to stop some public statement that had
been made about her and it ended up multiplying the statement.
Do you know when you try it?
This is the great thing about the Internet.
When you try to suppress something,
it grows.
It doesn't get suppressed.
The Internet,
including Dick Pictures and got one of those out there.
Come back around Graham Hancock.
I'm going to find you.
I've never had my dick photograph.
Congratulations.
How about you?
I plead the fifth
[inaudible]
freaks and geeks level.